okay I'm Dan Dennett and I didn't have
the scientific education I came from a
family
going back some generations of people in
the humanities English teachers
historians my father was historian I was
interested in science in school but I
was not particularly encouraged and
didn't do any science as an
undergraduate really did the minimal
amount it was only when I but I did work
with Quine who became my hero and mentor
and when I got to graduate school in
Oxford I got interested well I was
always interested in the mind and how it
worked and I had this bizarre eccentric
idea that it might help to know
something about the brain and this was
regarded by my fellow graduate students
as weird beyond belief I remember in
particular a discussion about what
happens for your when your arm goes to
sleep you know and you wake up to find
your hand
I sort of alien hand on your face or
something and I said well first of all
let's find out just what's going on in
the nervous system and and and there's
and they looked at me as if I'd said
first thing to do was get clear about
you know the mineral rights in China you
know they didn't see any reason to
explore these issues and I thought well
I sorry I just got to do that and I
began to educate myself this was an
Oxford in the Radcliffe Science Library
and spent much more time there than I
did in the philosophy so faculty library
and got my tutor my supervisor was
Gilbert Ryle it wasn't a scientific
fellow in his body but he somehow thing
goodness he sort of respected what I was
doing and he directed me to some good
people to be tutors and advisers and
that began my completely well to say I'm
autodidact is in one sense true but
actually is much better than that
because I learned just enough about
neuroscience and didn't call it that in
those days
so that when I got to my first job out
at a vine in 65 and we can tie him to
the cycle biologists they're basically
neuroscientists they were amazed that I
knew what I did they never encountered a
philosopher that was interested in new
and so they took it upon themselves to
educate me and I've had a world-class
list of tutors in psychology
neuroscience evolutionary biology
computer science
none of which I've ever studied formally
but I've had really super education from
them but all of course of this sort of
informal autodidact sort so that's how I
got to where do what I do and I don't
spend much time with philosophers these
days I don't actually let me say I think
this is a wonderfully chosen group when
I think of all the people in the field
of philosophy that aren't you I'm so
glad they're not we don't all agree as
you will soon see but but but we're all
very much in one corner of of the
discipline in our interest in and
respect for naturalism and science and
like oh and I am just appalled to see
how in spite of what I think is the
progress we've made in the last 25 years
there's this sort of retrograde gang
including some young ones then they're
going back to old-fashioned armchair
philosophy of mind with relish and an
eagerness and it just it's just
sickening because their work isn't worth
anything and they lure in other people
to do it it's it's cute it's clever and
it's not worth a damn
no it's the work that's not neither cute
nor clever and it's quite calm next well
there's stent yes so yeah but just going
around the table here all the issues
that have been raised or ones that
deeply important to me and I have a lot
to say about some of them before Alex
hope in his mouth I'd already written
the first thing I wrote down on the page
what I was going to talk about was
manifest image scientific image I am in
fact I believe that
Wilfred sellers nailed it he described
the job of philosopher that the one that
is a respectable and valuable service
and that is helping people with their
intuitions about how the manifest image
goes together with the scientific image
we know it doesn't go easily
and ever since Eddington and his two
tables and there's lots of scientists
who have tried and scientists aren't
particularly good at it and philosophers
aren't particularly good at it either if
they don't know the science what I think
you have to do is appreciate just how
you have to appreciate where the
manifest image came from how come there
is a manifest image what first I have
more to say about this later
there is the manifest image of the tick
font excuse kryb that it's the it's the
velvet it's the behavioral environment
there's that the manifest image of
people is very different from the
manifest image of anteaters or birds for
instance but it's as much a biological
fact about people at the manifest images
that's the world we live in and that's
that's the world of of colours and other
people and and rules and tables and
chairs and sunsets and all the rest the
the everyday common-sense world
and the scientific image is that does
not go under registration with that at
all well and the tribute somebody's job
many people's job to help nudge these
two images into greater Concilium but
help put them together I think that's
the best thing for a philosopher to do
and that's what I take myself to be
doing now Alex thinks that the manifest
image scientific image is not a valuable
things it's not a defensible distinction
that will be a topic for for a little
later but but I will first want to try
to show some of the positive things to
be said about the manifest image and how
it fits so many philosophers doing your
project why not basically make
pronouncing impossibilities
no it's it's it's in addition to sellers
famous remark about how things in the
broadest sense of things hang together
in the broadest sense of hang together
there's also a line about what
philosophy is that I like and that is a
flush is what you're doing when you're
not sure you're asking the right
questions think about it we we know
scientists who it makes you it makes her
teeth it really don't want it that they
want to get their questions cut and
dried and hanging on the rack and then
they go answer them and so there's that
side so yes we're all we're all in this
room in that sense we're all
philosophers I think Owen has the
naturalization of ethics as a big area
and I first of all I thought his this
book on the really hard problem was a
wonderful book I wrote a very positive
review of that
I think we can make progress on this and
I think that and I've been thinking this
for years down
down at the bottom of the barrel the
issue that is most pivotal is freewill
I've found neuroscientists who and Terry
almost said it I sort of if my brains a
computer I don't see how I can have free
will so I guess the brain isn't the
computer he didn't say that but no but
but but he raised the issue in a way
that I hope we will explore further the
issue about truth has come up and it's
interesting that there are some
philosophers and scientists who have
arrived at the position that believing
in free will is so important that we
should foster this as a holy myth even
though it ain't true
if I found myself in that camp I'd be in
deep trouble but in fact I find myself
in the camp saying but actually once you
understand what freewill is and what it
has to be in order to make life side
meaning there's no conflict at all it's
it's not a holy myth it's it's the it's
the literal non-metaphorical truth that
that compatibilism is true but it's it's
a little bit more convoluted story then
as often been now functionalism and
homunculus functionalism years ago I
said inspired really by working AI at
the time that I was working on here's
the way to do the mind you start with a
whole big mind you break it down into a
few sub minds that are that are that are
think of them as homunculus they're sort
of agencies they have their own agendas
to a certain scent they have their own
specializations
they interact it's a sort of social
interaction of these sub binds and they
in turn are made of sub sub Minds which
are made of sub sub sub Minds so you get
this cascade of
agency's down finally you get two little
machines little little agents that can
be replaced by a machine and at the time
I was thinking that's the neuron that's
the I was inspired by the McCulloch
Pitts logical neuron now of course we
know that McCulloch pits illogical
neurons argue laughably too simple now
I'm still a homunculus but I think we
have to take seriously that neurons are
selfish neurons to quote Sebastian
Seung's and and Terry was talking about
the way they send out their dendritic
explorations my view now which I'm
willing to be changed about or I like
that perhaps changed Terry's mind about
is that the brain is a largely anarchic
assemblage of selfish neurons which can
form coalition's and cabal's
and interact that you have to take their
their agendas seriously and then you get
a model of computation which is
profoundly unlike the model that handles
the lab it's still computation because
as alex says it's an information or or
as Don was saying it's an information
informational processing system but it's
also a sort of an economic system in a
certain way so that we save the idea of
the brain as a computer we save
functionalism by abandoning a rigid
hierarchical eric bound computer
scientist has a great word for the
mistake in architecture she calls them
politbureau
architectures which i think exactly
captures what's wrong with the standard
image of computation in the brain so
what I would be interested to see if
anybody can change my mind about is the
manifest image I think that it's not
just pro tam that we've got the man
first image and that we can we all start
there and then we move off into a
scientific image which simply abandons
the manifest image I think once we
understand how the manifest image arises
the roles it plays in in life including
the life of the scientist we see that we
want to clarify the relationships
between the manifest image and the
scientific image and although the
scientific image has priority in one
sense it doesn't usurp the the ground of
the manifest image at the end of the day
Oh Rebecca said you know you know
there's no colors in one sense there's
no colors atoms aren't colored just like
a magnetic radiation visible spectrum so
forth but there's another sense which
requestors colors I mean if you say hey
there's no color television set in my
hotel room and they say well of course
not because there's no color you would
think well hey there's the sense which
it's obvious that there's color that's
in the manifest image we've got to make
sense of that
you